- Y'all, you like to travel,
you and your wife, right?
- Yes, very much.
- And I think last time y'all
were doing a trip to Napa.
- Yes.
- I think, was it lovely?
- Yeah, we did have a good time.
We went down and we saw her father,
and we had a very good time.
We like to travel together a lot.
We've been married for
27 years and we really.
(audience clapping)
- [Kelly] Wow.
- Wait, that's like
striking out the picture.
That was the easiest.
That was the easiest applause.
But no, we've been married for 27 years
and now it's that time, you know,
the kids have stepped outta the house
and we have more time to
spend together and so.
- Get to date again.
- We do.
- I like it.
- And so we found, we had
a plan to do some trips
and one of them was to go to Spain,
to do the Camino de Santiago,
which is a trail that
takes you from France,
on the French side of the Pyrenees.
And you go over to Spain,
then you go to Santiago De Compostela,
which is about a 500 mile walk and.
- So it is true, there's
someone for everyone.
(Kelly giggles)
- Well, I didn't know whether we'd last,
to tell you the truth.
When you walk with someone for 500 miles,
that's a problem.
- No, just walking for
500 miles in general,
sounds like, unless there's wine.
(Kelly giggles)
Well, how did the trip go?
Did it?
- It was great, it was fantastic.
- [Kelly] Beautiful probably.
- We didn't, make it the whole way,
'cause I ended up with, with shin splints.
But besides that, the first day was,
walking over the Pyrenees,
the second day was moving on through Spain
and we did about 220 miles
and it was incredible.
And it was fun too because first,
you gotta get your backpack,
you gotta get all your parts
together and this and that.
- Oh, that's the part I lack, the prep.
- And I was.
- Buying all the fun stuff.
- Exactly.
You get to buy all the
stuff and pack it up.
And I was all excited about,
I told her I've got it all planned out.
We're gonna have our bags, you know,
taken from spot to spot, to hotel to hotel
and it's gonna be great.
And she goes, we're not doing that.
- What?
- So what do you mean?
She goes, well, we're just
gonna stay wherever we stay.
I said, where's that gonna be?
She goes, I don't know.
She goes, maybe the Albergues
or the hostels or wherever.
That's where we'll stay.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I said.
- I love that free spirited, yeah.
- No, I said, no, no.
I said, are you nuts?
But that's what we did
because she said yes.
And it was a blast.
We had the time of our lives.
- I love that, being unplanned.
Like it's like planned when like you,
I just love that you're
staying in a hostel.
- That's it.
That was my top bunk.
And she stayed on the other top bunk
and the people behind,
below us that night,
remember that Cat?
They were not happy people.